hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today we're
gonna continue on with what we were
doing yesterday and once we start coding
I'll give a little recap of what we did
yesterday in case you missed it you can
always go back and watch the recording
of the stream they're all available on
the free code camp YouTube channel
everything's in the live coding with
Jesse playlist probably gonna break
those out into some some other playlists
but we'll always keep keep the one big
playlist so it's easy to find everything
I just want to say I want to explain a
little bit about the technical
difficulties that have been going on in
the last few streams because I think we
finally figured it out so hard [ __ ] and
rook both pointed out to me that one of
the extensions that I was using in
Visual Studio code it was taking up a
lot of resources so I hadn't even
thought about that I kept looking at all
the programs that I had open not even
for whatever reason it just didn't cross
my mind at all to check out Visual
Studio code but I think that's the
problem
right now the stream seems to be going
fine let me know if it if it's not
working for you but I've the plugin is
called what was it import cost display
yeah the plugin is called import cost so
you may have the plug-in and not even
realize it
I know I've recommended in the past to
download the react food-truck extension
I'm sorry I keep calling it plugins but
a Visual Studio code the code extensions
so if you have the react food-truck
extension for Visual Studio code it may
have automatically downloaded the import
cost extension as well so if you're
having issues with your computer being
sluggish and it just started you know
recently after
you've you know downloaded that check it
out you know try disabling it that
seemed to be my problem so hopefully we
have everything figured out now that
wasn't a really cool extension but it
wasn't it wasn't necessary I can see
maybe turning it on just to check
everything once or twice and then
turning it back off definitely not
something that I need on all the time so
not really a big deal but I just want to
let everybody know since I feel kind of
bad because I recommended that and it
may be crashing computers out there okay
Brooke mentions in the live chat that
rook went searching for issues with that
plugin after Harshit mentioned it so
thanks for giving credit where does do
harsh it is the one that that first
thought of it and then rook helped out
by sending me some links to some github
issues about it so it's it definitely it
wasn't just just me or just harsh it a
lot of other people have the notice the
same same issues with that extension all
right we're gonna get started I'm gonna
briefly check the live chat see if
there's anything that I should address
right now once we get started I'm gonna
take a little while but 25 minutes to do
some coding and then I'll take a break
and go back to the live chat and do some
coding again after so just be patient if
you ask something in the live chat I may
not see it right away but I will get to
it eventually
also I'm I have a cough I'm a little
congested have a cough so if I sound
weird and a cough a lot that's that's
why I apologize I'll try not to do it
too much I'm a little out of it
I hope I'm not getting sick again
there's been sick way too much lately
but I'm gonna do my best and I'm sure
you all keep me on track if I do
something weird we do have one one
question that I'd like to address the
boat froyo says I cloned the project
from github into a folder and in
I did I open get bash and the and run
the npm install command so that it
installs the dependencies it's getting
me errors i cant npm started de proprio
how the boat pre oh sorry i'm sorry i'm
really already get that right i'm not
sure if i'm pronouncing it right but
what version of node are you running
sometimes we run some stuff that
requires a later version of node i don't
think we are on this project but i'm not
100% sure so that could be it if you are
running like the latest version of node
then that's probably fine maybe if you
could let me know specifically what some
of the errors are I could try to try to
figure them out let's see
alright I'm gonna it looks like there's
some other stuff in the live chat but
I'll get to that after we do some coding
so let's get started and let me switch
my screens there we are
so I left this sidebar up just to show
you again it's the import cost plugin so
if you have this and it's causing
problems you can just disable it and you
should be alright after that and we'll
find out cuz when I start doing things
if the stream gets really laggy and
drops frames and stuff then we'll know
the really good news though is I don't
think there's anything wrong with my
network I was afraid that something
happened and I didn't have the same
network speed as I did normally and that
would have been a disaster because if
I'm trying to stream every day like I
need a good network so it seems like
it's ok I did a network speed test I can
actually stream at a much higher
resolution than I am now I could
probably stream 4k if I wanted to and as
long as my machine could handle it so
basically my networks amazing
I just I'm limited by my computer's
capabilities
maybe one day I'll try to stream really
high-quality there's no reason to but it
might just be cool to see if it could
work I wouldn't experiment like that on
the free code camp channel though I'll
probably do it on my own but if I mess
it up it's not that many people will be
affected by it all right let me start
and grow up so I'm gonna about to paste
a link into the live chat if you click
that link you'll be able to see the
project as we're working on it you can
inspect it in in dev tools and it'll be
a lot easier for you all to really kind
of see what's going on for yourself and
I haven't said this for a while but I do
want to thank
the the guy who made and rock which I
can't remember his name right now but
his Twitter handle is at inconceivable
so you can see it right there who's
letting us use and rock for free at a
level that you know normally you'd have
to pay money for for this many
connections at once I don't even know if
it's a set plan yeah even to have this
many connections so very very generous
and so if if you get a chance and you're
in a position to use the paid version of
and rock sometime
highly recommended the like I said the
guy who who works on and who made it is
seems to be a really good guy from from
the interaction that I've had with him
alright let's get our Pomodoro timer
started and let me bring over I I said I
was gonna go over what I did earlier or
what we did yesterday so I'll do that so
basically yesterday all we did doesn't
seem like much but it did take a while
we just made each one of these Inbox
really sorry each one of these menu
items that you can open and close the
submenu is now a component it's it's an
instance of this one component and it
they each have their own state and
that's working fine we stop there but
here's the goal for today what we want
to happen is when I click on one of
these so let's say I clicked on this
about menu item I want the side nav the
sides were to open and I would like the
corresponding so let's say that this
inbox was really about I want it to be
opened as well so first step is
let's get this side drawer to open when
we click on one of these
we'll get that working and then we'll
tackle the final piece and I'd like to
break it down and in this way because
you can take little steps test the steps
and you know make commits that are kind
of like logical little chunks and it
just makes it seem less overwhelming in
general all right so here's our drawer
item that's the component that we made
yesterday we're gonna leave this alone
for now
we'll come back to it later hopefully if
we have time and can get this other
stuff worked out here's our layout
component our layout component is the
parent component of our our top nav our
app bar and our drawer so if we need to
be able to share state between these
between the drawer and the app bar then
we ought to have something living here
in the layout ojs component all right so
let's see we did do some work yesterday
so let me try to remember what we did so
we can just build on that so we already
have state here and that's the drawer so
I guess a drawer is if it's false it's
not open if it's true it is open we
already have this toggle drawer here
which is wonderful that's what you want
we also have this expand item function
here which we're not using yet but
eventually we're gonna go back to this
so for right now all we're worried about
is this toggle drawer and let's see our
drawer component and we're passing down
this state drawer so open true or false
which is great and then we also are
passing down this toggle words Wharf
and now you can see in the drawer we
have we should have a click on close
okay so we calling toggle drawer here
we're passing it down as a prop and we
also should have its the button oh you
know what it's in it's in a part we're
passing down toggles we're in the app
bar great okay so we're already passing
in to app bar what we need so this will
be not that hard
let's get that bar out here alright
looks like we have some stuff going on
here comment it out move to go back to
that probably not in today's stream but
I've to go back to it and see what what
we were doing here alright so these are
all just styles we've done the styles as
a JavaScript object that's one way you
can do things in react
we're not gonna mess with styles too
much today but we have in some previous
streams if you're interested all right
so we're bringing in toggle drawer here
as prop so normally you have to do like
this props and then whatever you want
but we are doing so we're passing props
in here so we don't need that this and
then here I believe this is
destructuring correct me if I'm wrong
where this is called object
destructuring I think and and we're
saying it equals prop so now we can just
use toggle drawer inside of this
function and it'll it'll work just save
some space so not really worth it if
you're only using it like once or twice
but if you're using it more than that
like we're using classes it
really cleans things up a lot but it can
be confusing if you haven't seen it
before so just wanted to point that out
all right so we need to find the menu
items this components pretty cluttered
right now we're gonna refactor this but
there's no sense in refactoring until we
really haven't built out the way we want
we may end up doing some unnecessary
factoring otherwise and we just don't
really have time to do all that we have
a tight deadline so this this thing
needs to be done in a month like ready
to go live I'm feeling a little pressure
right now cuz I do have some other sites
that I need to work on as well I'm
expecting I'm gonna be working late
February is gonna be is gonna be rough
let's see
there we alright so this is this is what
we want let's put an on click you know
what we already put on click handler
down here now I remember we did this we
did this recently so we don't want yeah
we don't want this we don't need this
open side drawer we need what did we
call it toggle toggle drawer yeah toggle
drawer let's make sure okay
now I added this in here we don't need
obviously we don't need to pass this in
right if we go to our our layout where
we have toggle drawer we're not we don't
need to use anything but I'm gonna keep
it in for right now because this is one
potential way that we may end up doing
the next step and expanding that menu
item so I'm gonna leave it in there for
now it shouldn't mess anything up but
we'll see alright so that saves which
one alright so if we click the faith in
life link we should open all right
awesome
that was way easier than I thought we
had pretty much had everything already
written everything done so I'm clicking
on this and it works wonderful now would
be a great time I think to refactor a
bit and take these out and make them
their own component and that should
clean up should clean up a decent amount
in here and while this is all still
fresh in our minds I think it would be
good because we can pass down this
toggle drawer again another level you
can see we're starting to get a little
complicated with passing things down
maybe I might want to start thinking
about using something else to manage
state other than just like component
state left to think about it I'm not
ready to switch quite yet I'm still okay
with this but I'm right on the edge if
we go like another level of having to
pass things down I'm not comfortable
with that it was starting to get too
complicated okay so let's make another
component and let's just copy and paste
a lot of what we did here save some time
and we'll remove let's see we don't need
using classes should grab the whole li
yeah we'll grab the whole Li let's copy
that and then inside of here we'll
replace this div that's what we have
here yes let me save this so we can get
our syntax highlighting
we're in components and let's call this
should we call this menu item
yeah that's what it is I usually like
shorter names but that describes things
accurately so we'll stay with that it's
fixed our indentation a bit get rid of
those lines and it's we're not importing
typography so I think that's why we're
getting this yep what it's not defined
so let's make sure we define that and
let's see if we can just grab it no I
just like to copy and paste when I can
here we are
so let's import typography and we don't
need either one of these I think who are
using no no we don't need any that we
don't need collapse or the expand there
we are and let's see what styles we do
need so we need classes list Li and
classes ul link so let's find it over
here I'm gonna leave them in here for
now before I I need to double check to
make sure these aren't being used
elsewhere in this component before I get
rid of them so let's add this in here we
can get rid of nested because we're not
using that and remember this object is
just our Styles think about this just
like you see at your stylesheet and we
did have all these styles in this
component but now since we're moving or
markup right if this were just HTML
we're basically moving our HTML from one
HTML file over to another one so if we
want the styles to be applied we have to
move the styles over as well and the UL
link is the other one that we need so
now these Styles look a little different
than you're used to if you you're just
using CSS or sass but really it's not
that hard just imagine everywhere where
you'd normally put a hyphen instead you
camelcase things it's basically the same
is that for the most part you need to
put quotation marks around a lot of your
values but other than that it's very
very similar to normal CSS alright so
now we should have all the Styles that
we need we need to change the name here
because we're using we don't want it to
be drawer item so let's change it now to
app bar menu item save that and alright
we need to pass down some information
right because we don't want all of them
to say the same thing and link to the
same thing so first let's let's import
this so let's import it's the app bar
menu item from that bar menu item
so now we can use this it's red because
we haven't used it yet but now we can
use this down here so let's go back to
where we had all these and we'll replace
each one with our new component and
that's just shorten things up quite a
bit so here we are here's our component
so we're gonna make within this UL right
remember because we have our allies over
here in our new component we're going to
make four of these new components
eventually will actually store for
probably store a lot of the data
separately pull it in and just map over
the data so we can make the markup you
know even shorter but for now we only
have four it's it's not really a big
deal to act
we have four components here I see a lot
of activity in the live chat as well
just hang in there if you if you have a
question in about ten minutes I'm going
to go back to the live chat and answer
some questions so let's make our menu
item
let's use our what was an app bar menu
item and we need to pass some things
down as props so we definitely need
toggle drawer and we're just gonna say
toggle drawer and I think we can do it
like that because we've destructured it
up here let me double check though yes
we have so we can do toggle drawer and
let me clarify as well but that's how
we've done it here yep all right so we
can add wide toggle drawer and then we
also need to add a title and ID and our
text here and if we use the ID here as
well if we just make it the same then I
think we could save ourselves from
having to pass in two different props
for that so let's let's do that
I'd say here's our first I'm gonna write
it like this since we're gonna have a
few props here be easier to to see so
we'll need an ID
let's do link ID I don't want it to be
confused I don't want there to be any
confusion about you know what we're
using here so that's why I'm putting
link ID instead of just a normal ID and
in this case we're gonna put let's go
I'm just gonna say faith in life and now
we can add these here 2d structures so
we can still use and actually never
double check to make sure destruction
was the right word
hopefully I'm using that correctly all
right good object destruction good thank
you rep for clarifying that for me I
just don't want to mess people up and
say the wrong thing and I think that
somebody something happened and they
messed something up just because I can't
remember the right words alright so we
have linked ID right so we called it
yeah linked ID and now we'll use title
and let's do face
and life let's change that up let's say
content faith in life and we can reuse
that for the title as well
alright now let's change things over
here so that we can use this so here
we're going to bring in link ID and
we're also gonna use our link ID here
link ID do I have to we'll see if that
works let me know though do I need to
put link ID in here I always forget when
I'm using arrow functions in in here let
me know we'll find out as soon as I save
this and see if I get an error
all right the href you know what we need
the 8 do we need the href no we really
don't because we're not actually linking
to anything all right we don't need to
worry about that we may even be able to
take this out completely let's try to
take the href out all right for our
title we're just gonna add content and
we're also gonna use it down here so
down here right this is just the content
to your content of this component and
we're gonna add our curly brackets that
means we can put JavaScript inside of
there so I can just say content whoops
this has to be inside and that will pull
in whatever value we pass in which in
this case is going to be faith in life
this looks good oops we can get rid of
this so we don't actually need this and
we could refactor this to a stateless
functional component I'm not gonna do it
right now so we want to make sure we
have time to actually get things working
but
you can see right now we really aren't
doing much of anything in here so we
could shorten this up a bit and make it
a functional component all right so I'm
gonna save that and this component
should be ready
I don't unless I messed something up
this should be done now let's copy this
and paste it a few times two three and
now we're just gonna change the names
and this one will be about
I believe the next one is academics
oops lower case and admissions
admissions now let's delete all of these
whoa too far
area
all right wonderful so here's our four
links what did I mess up here this
trailing space is not allowed there we
are
alright let's save that and see what we
have all right no errors
excellent and since I removed that href
you can see I don't automatically have
the little cursor pointer that makes it
look like it's clickable we can add that
in I think I'd rather not have the HR if
in fact let me remove this little
pounced on the hashtag there and let's
see great that works that works that
works that works wonderful okay they all
work so I said the last thing I want to
move in is this you will link I want to
add cursor:pointer so if you ever want
something to have that cursor you know
normally on a web page when you have an
a tag of a link you hover over it the
cursor changes if you want that to
happen on some other element you could
just add cursor:pointer in the CSS so
let's save that and see if it works and
if it did see so now we have that little
hand icon wonderful alright so we only
have about just over 30 seconds left
until the break so I'm just going to go
in to the live chat right now and answer
a few questions actually you know what
it'll be a good idea to commit let's do
a git status so we've added a component
here or we've we've modified at bar and
then we've actually added this app bar
menu item component so let's do a git
add right and I could do the little
period that adds everything and then we
need to do a git come
it and without when we commit I'll do
the M flag then I can put my commit
message in line create
create components for a par menu items
alright that works now it's going to go
through all its tests it's gonna
automatically Anders that we're using
and it also Lentz everything so two
checks all of our code and now it's
going to do testing it actually opens up
or pay some of our pages in a browser
make sure that certain elements are
there on the page and we've passed all
the tests now we can push so we're gonna
do a get push now I know yesterday we
found out from rook that you can
actually just type and get push but
there are some caveats to that it
doesn't work in every situation so I'm
not going to do that because I don't
want to confuse anyone who's new with
get if they try to do it like that and
can't understand why it's it's not
working because you know potentially
they may not have seen when we did that
and I don't want to have to repeat the
caveats every time so I'm just going to
stick with git push origin and hit enter
Oh what I need the passphrase so
thankfully LastPass is working this time
yesterday it didn't work so I can get
the password for this much more quickly
let's paste that in and then I'm gonna
do this is H add and paste it again and
then that way I won't have to enter it
again as long as I don't restart my
computer now all this code is in our
github repo on the master branch so if
you want to check out anything that
we've done check it out now if you
already have the code everything cloned
then you can do a get pool to get it if
you fork the repo first actually I don't
there's another step right if you forked
it and then download it you need to
update your fork correct but basically
the codes all up-to-date on this
repository on the master branch now so
let me set the five-minute timer and I'm
gonna go to the live chat let me scroll
up a bit
blake ass how's your day been actually
not not too bad I I felt like I said I
felt congested a sore throat when I woke
up but I actually I woke up and I got in
a little workout which was so this is
day four that I've worked out every day
for four days which probably sounds like
not that impressive but for me it's
super impressive because I my workout
schedule has been so off I can't even
remember the last time I worked out four
days in a row so I think that's been
contributing to me being sick so much if
you watch the streams a lot I think you
may have noticed that I've been sick I
don't know it seems like way more than a
normal person should be sick I think
part of it may be because I haven't been
exercising so anyway I got in a workout
but I still I feel really tired and I
had a meeting this morning which it was
hard to stay awake during the meeting
but I got through that and everything's
going all right the only thing that I
only think I can complain about is
somebody like it was not very nice to my
wife in the comment section of a blog
post and that made me upset but my wife
for spawning she can handle herself
she's tough but other than that I'm okay
that kind of made me a little bit angry
and my my bitcoin and litecoin
and ether investments are going up today
kind of had a little dip yesterday so
that makes me happy I don't really have
that much money in it I just gotta have
a little bit to play around in so not
sure if you wanted the whole recap of my
day but there it is rook says that that
extension we were talking about earlier
should perform better with the latest
update so I maybe I'll try that like I
said earlier I don't really think that
was that plug in code I import cost I
don't really think the import cost
plug-in is necessary for my work so it
probably won't turn
again for a while like if at all but
it's good to know that they're working
on the performance improvements Vivek
asked what language were going to code
in mostly JavaScript react style
JavaScript hard says West boss recently
released a cool free CSS grid course
that's cool yeah I saw some people on
Instagram and on Twitter where we're
posting about that so yeah check that
out if you want an intro to CSS grid I
haven't really done any of the West boss
courses but so many other developers say
that they're really good so if I get
some time one day I'm definitely gonna
check that out okay harsh it's gonna do
the course today hardship please let me
know how it is if it's if you think it
would be helpful because I definitely
need to learn more about CSS grid
Harshit says the the URL is CSS grid dot
io Deb de beaupré o says he's running
eight point nine point four for his note
version yeah that should work that
should be fine so it's definitely not
your version
Oh hard [ __ ] you got it all right so de
beaupré Oh says running npm start caused
errors and harsh it says npm start is
for production we have to run Liz it run
dev is that what we use I get confused
with that because where's our package
JSON file depending on the project we
sometimes have different commands for
starting servers for development in
production there it is
yeah you want to go with npm dev or yarn
dev or npm run dev or whatever you want
to do and that that should work let me
know if that doesn't work
Peter as says what peripherals do you
use with your Mac I use this thing the
touchpad would out they call it the
magic something I don't know all this
stuff with Mac is called magic whatever
it's not really magic it's just
technology right I don't know but I
really love this thing this is the best
touchpad that I've ever used it was
weird to get used to it at first but
mostly all like the hand gestures are my
favorite thing so there are some things
that are easier to do with the mouse but
I've gotten used to this and I kind of
liked it and then my keyboard is just
the normal standard Mac keyboard so I've
thought about getting a different
keyboard everybody talks about these
mechanical keyboards I might get one one
day but for now this this works fine all
right let me get back to the code
[Music]
all right so I know I didn't get through
everything in the live chat so sorry if
I didn't get to your question or comment
yet I will definitely get to it before I
end the stream so just hang in there if
you can if you have to go that's cool
you can always check out the stream
later on when the recordings available
and you can listen in for my answer to
your question then all right so let's go
to alright next step start our timer
here's our next step so now we have this
opens when we click it but we want more
we want it to not only open but also
open this side menu the appropriate one
so we're gonna first thing we're gonna
do is let's make four sections here and
let's name them we'll give them the
proper names to match these it'll be
easier to just think about it and see if
it's working so that'll be an easy first
step to get us started pretty sure we
can do that and there won't be any
issues let's get rid of our package.json
I don't need that anymore
and our drawer item components so we
need to go so our drawer item component
when we made it yesterday we never took
the step to pass down props we have
values hard-coded so we need to do that
so we just did it with the app bar menu
we're gonna do the same thing again so
this will be good if you're kind of new
to this you maybe were a little confused
by what we were doing with our props
we're gonna do it again let's see where
we are drawer so let's go to our drawer
and we can see here's where we're
bringing in this dry them so we have our
drawer item here but we need a few more
things
we need this primary text and what else
do we need
yeah we're gonna need primary text for
sure
I'm thinking I might want to call it
something different but I don't know
what so I'll stick with primary text for
right now and in this case our primary
text is going to be what was the first
one about so it'll be about and let's
add
[Music]
all right let's get for that level
let's add something else this is our
[Music]
submenu items and what we're gonna need
to do for our submenu items is have an
array of objects so for now I'm just
gonna do some stuff as a demo we're
obviously not going to want to have this
all right here where we're gonna put in
a component
this is gonna be elsewhere either in
this component or preferably in a data
file and then we'll pull it in and when
we get to that part probably not going
to get to today but later on we'll get
to it and if I react to it you know when
i'm not streaming and you want to know
how it works you can always check out
the code and you could ask me on a
stream and I'll kind of walk through it
so we put our curly braces here so that
that means hey we're going into
JavaScript land so anything we put in
here will be JavaScript and now we have
an array and we're gonna have an array
of objects right so we need more curly
braces and we're gonna have we'll have
key value pairs so we'll have text
and in this case you know and I'm gonna
bring up on my other screen I'm going to
bring up the current site as it is just
to give a get a few you know forget it
I'm not gonna do that let's just do
let's keep it simple
link 1 and text link 1 and then we're
gonna need a link URL which is gonna be
for now let's just give it a hash all
right but you can see how this is going
to work out so let me copy this and
we're going to paste it a few times
all right so we'll have three items
underneath that's good let me clean this
up a bit so it'll be a little easier
just to see what's going on Oh what is
going on here
all right I was attempting to format
this properly but it's just not it's not
working let's see
this one are you able to see the
structure here of what we have of key
value pairs no no for for some of you
this is going to be you know an easier
concept but this could potentially be
confusing if you haven't kind of seen
this before so hopefully this is a
little bit easier I'll be I can't keep
it in this format but it would then
these would just be too huge but you can
see our submenu items so we're gonna
have link one we'll change this to link
2 and Link 3 and the reason we're doing
this as an array of objects is that now
when we pass this over we'll be able to
use map on these and just go through
everything and keep making this
collapsible will not to collapse these
list items here we can just go down
through and just add in as many list
items as we want and we can pass in a
different array for each drawer item
here so it if it's not all making sense
to you now if you're if you worked with
react and seeing some more freeze
projects hopefully you can kind of
visualize what's going to happen here if
it doesn't make sense now we'll make a
lot more sense once we get some real
data in here but now that we have this
let's I'm gonna copy and paste let me
verify that I don't need anything else
this
all right not bad if we do want these to
be links we're gonna have to add
something else in here but for right now
this this will just work we're not
really trying to to demonstrate the
links cuz we don't even have most these
pages built out all right so let's get
rid of these we have one two three four
great so we'll just change the names up
here it will bounce academics Admissions
and faith in life okay let's save it and
now
we need to bring these in so let's use
our destructuring or object
destructuring again save us some space
save us some typing so we'll have our
primary text and we'll also have our sub
menu items so menu items
great here this is gonna be a primary
text and then down here this is gonna be
a little bit more complicated so within
our collapse and our list we have all
these list items so what we want to do
here is go into some Java scripts right
and let's say what did we call it
submenu submenu items dot map what is
this I'm just an accessory arguments the
map method back cool it gives me a
little explanation of this awesome
alright so we're going to say items
and so let's just happen let's let's
make this a little bit easier to read so
many items so many new items thought map
so each each thing is going to be called
item and then within there we want to
bring in this list item so let's copy
that and paste it in well I've got a lot
of red right now all trailing spaces
just missing key prop yeah yeah we'll be
fine
a lot of this red will go away as we go
so it's true we do need a key problem
and we will use as clean yourself a bit
make it a little easier as a key we're
going to use the but geez we can't use
the euro it will be different we'll just
use the text for now
oops it'll be item dot text right so
we're gonna have access to this text and
URL for each item so think of it like a
loop if you're not familiar with map
like imagine that we're looping through
each one of these objects in this array
and so each one of those objects if it
would be the same as if we did like item
and then in brackets you know zero so
it's the first item and the next time it
will be item 1 item 2 right but we don't
have to do that with map so item dot
Texas or key for now probably won't be
the key forever or should I see you just
said use index I'm maybe I don't I
usually would like to use something else
other than index but not usually as you
know it's a string like that for right
now this will work and we need to insert
here item text and we'll add in just so
that we have it here somewhere we're
gonna add in link URL equals link URL
whoops
item dot link URL ok now let's see
everything indentation and
I think these are all indentation things
which are okay all right not worried
about that let's get rid of this and
just gonna glance through this again one
more time all right looks good looks
good all right let's save let's make
sure we save this let's go back here no
errors excellent let's check over here
all right we have about link 1 2 3 drink
1 2 3 1 2 3 excellent alright and as we
click these write nothing happens which
is to be expected right now but we have
successfully pull these out put them in
another component to each one of these
has its own component and each one can
take an array of objects to make as many
links underneath as we want which is
great doesn't seem like a big deal now
but when we end up wanting to put all
these links in it's gonna be a really
nice feature to be able to just pass in
an array all right okay now here's the
hard that the part that I've been
wondering about and I'm still not
exactly sure how we're going to do it
I should commit this though right now
before we do that all right
get
right on
oh you know what we already made that I
was just confused because it says we
just modified it I forgot that we
actually made this component yesterday
we just didn't really finish making it
to be fully functional all right it's
all right so I'm gonna do a git commit
with the am flag which means I'm adding
it and sending the message at the same
time as I'm committing and we'll say
it's
okay that works we're gonna run through
all our tests do our Auto formatting if
you notice here look all of our red
lines are already gone it's formatted
everything properly for us which is
awesome it saves us time from having to
go through and try to fix those lines
great we passed and now we'll do a git
push origin right and now that's up on
github alright let's let's think for a
second about how we're gonna do this
let's go back out here so again the
desired functionality is that we click
on about the side nav opens which we've
already covered that but I also want
this to be expanded so first step is
let's figure out what makes this expand
or not expand and then we can try to
figure out how to influence that so
we'll go to our component that's dry
them component and let's see here's our
component that's the collapsed component
and
expand less okay this is probably for
our icon so we're not worried about that
so what we are worried about is this I
believe I believe it's this one is in
state open items so if our value for
collapse in is true it's open if it's
false it's closed I think that's what's
going on here correct me if I'm wrong so
we need somehow to be able to modify
this when a click occurs okay
and this is where I wish like I wasn't I
wasn't kind of sick because I really
want my whole brain to be on this one
alright alright so my original idea was
just to have this state live and lay out
which is the parent component but the
problem became if the state lives in
layout then when we click one of these
all of them would open or close
so that's why we move state here and we
move these to a component so it makes
sense for this component to be able to
control whether it's open or closed
another thought potentially could be
I just keep going back to read us and
thinking about oh I would do it like
this in redux
really that is what we need if we were
to bring the state up to lay out what we
would need is a separate state for each
item in that menu right now we can art
code that and that would be fine but
that wouldn't work as well if we were
gonna have lots of menu items now the
realistically were we're not gonna have
a lot of menu items it's probably only
going to be four that have the expansion
we're gonna add maybe a few more that
won't be expandable Harshit does say
that apollo has a link state and because
Apollo has the Redux replacement all
right so Harsha did write a blog post on
that maybe I'll check that out let me
let me work through this
I'll tell you what I want - let's try to
do this just with component state then
Harsha I'll read your blog post on that
and maybe we'll go back and refactor it
and the only reason I'm even comfortable
doing this with the component state is
because those links will most likely
never change those main links they've
never changed on the website for years
and my boss wants to keep them as is so
I guess I'm ok with this
normally I wouldn't just normally it
would not ever make sense to hard-code
stuff like that in like the the links
but let me show you a way we could
possibly do this if you weren't if you
didn't want to use redux or apollo's
Redux like thing that's that they have
now so in our layout component under
state let's go with shoot hold on let me
see
understate let's have
see if we can do this
about fools academics
life all right
Sunita come on all right save that
hopefully I can see where I'm going with
this
and then we need to pass these values
down I'm not exactly sure if I can even
do this in here
why did I make this in a ray you don't
need that
okay so drawer items is an object that
has key value pairs for each of the kind
of drop-down things that we want tell
you what my timer went off my timer went
off let me take five minutes here go to
the live chat I'm going to answer some
more questions and then we'll come back
and finish off this my point my goal is
just to get the functionality that we
want it may not be the best way to do it
but we can always refactor that's
generally the way I like to go about
things is get it to work first then
worry about refactoring then that's
especially how I like to do things when
something needs to be done quickly
because if worse comes to worst we can
always use the way that works puts not
ideal and then go back to it you know at
some later point let me scroll back up
to why I left off
all right so andrew says hey Jesse
congratulations on finishing the
nanodegree I really enjoyed your review
and thank you again for letting us get a
peek into your day to day work
oh you're welcome and I'm glad glad you
liked the video sorry about being so
late on that I know I had said that I
was gonna make a video for a long time
I finished my nano degree way back at
like the end of October or something
beginning of November and it took me you
know this long until January to get the
video made so it's finally out there if
you haven't seen it yet and you're
interested there's a link to my YouTube
channel in the description of this video
check it out it's the latest video on
there it's it's my review of my
experience with the react nanodegree if
you don't have time the video is only a
few minutes long but if you don't have
time my overall assessment is I think it
was a good use of my time and money to
do the nanodegree program I learned a
lot so if you're in a situation where it
makes sense for you I would recommend it
Peter asked how do you jump back the
indentation so yeah it's shift-tab so if
you want to you can highlight within
your code editor you can highlight a
block of text and then tab to go forward
shift tab to go backward let's see John
Hanson says you can pass it down unclick
events and even reuse on toggle drawer
though it can get messy unless you
control bubbling and capturing event
stop propagation fixes many issues okay
good to know
Brooke says how do you do pseudo
selectors or media queries and that
inline CSS support it no inline CSS does
not support media queries so if you want
to do media queries you you you can't do
it inline as far as I know last time I
checked if there's anything change then
I sorry
let me know but yeah you can't do that
and pseudo selectors yes so if you want
to do pseudo selector like before or
after that doesn't work in line either
so you are you can only use a subset of
CSS if you want to go strictly inline
brooks says when you see a squiggly line
and want to see the error you can press
f8 or just hover over it okay that's
good to know sometimes it's hard to get
a hover on it if it's a tiny squiggly
line so f8 cool I learned so many useful
things from you all I really appreciate
that Peter says all those tests and
stuff when you commit to are they
default or do you have to add them he
says I'm a total get new oh don't worry
about it
we're all noobs at something I'm sure if
there's just way too much going on and
even within web development there's way
too many things to be an expert at
everything so Peter we did have to make
those tests and by we I mean Harshit he
made the test
so yeah they don't come by default you
can you know get take a look at some of
the code maybe we'll do a stream or we
maybe write some tests that might be
that might be a good thing to do I need
myself to learn more about tests so
maybe we'll try to do that depending on
the time though that might be something
that we do a stream about after we
launch the site because that's not
usually a good idea but unfortunately we
just don't have a lot of time to get it
launched vivek says hello hey Vivek
thanks for joining us Evos here hey ebo
how's it going Oh hard should said we
have instructions for the fork and the
contributing file so I did mention
before about cloning and forking the
repo so check out our contributing file
contributing MD that's in the repository
it'll give you a lot more info about
that thank you for bringing that up
portion Vivek asks what language I use
Java scripts
let's see
Excel says get ad dot is for a doll to
state like - a I guess I didn't I never
use - a four also yeah the dot the
little period after get ad that means
also you just add everything to be ready
I think they call it it's staged when
you do that so you staged everything to
be committed alright I'll come right
back to where I left off in the live
stream after we finish this this next
coding session so here's what I'm going
to do we're gonna try to make this work
in the next session if the next session
ends before it works I'm still gonna
finish and we'll just I'll work on it
later hopefully we'll get it done if I
can get it done before the session is
over then I'll just go straight to the
questions
so right now I've added in the a parent
component layout Jas I've added this
droid items in the state and I have
key-value pairs for each of our items
each of our main links that will have
the you know collapsible so now we want
to be able to pass this down so the
first thing I think we should do is try
to pass these down to our to our drawer
items and see if we can control them
being open or closed just by kind of
changing them here in our file so we
need to pass it down to the drawer first
so in drawer let's go with drawer items
equals this the state dot drawer excuse
me draw items and that's probably just a
space yeah indentation thing all right
so we're passing drawer items good we
shouldn't have any errors yet excellent
now from drawer let's go into our drawer
and let's pass down
and this is going to be a little bit
weird that we're doing it like this for
now we wouldn't want to keep it like
this but we are just for now so we're
gonna say let's see
is open and he is open value we're gonna
give it it's gonna be this props drawer
items dot about
just make sense thank you Rick said
bless you exist nice thank you
right and normally we wouldn't do this
like copy and paste at all we would be
mapping over these things just like we
did in our drawer item component which
is what we're gonna go to next we would
we would do did we do the map here yeah
right here is our map so eventually
we'll refactor and do that so let's see
about academics admissions and then here
if you remember I had hyphens so we
can't keep the hyphens in there so we're
gonna have to use our brackets in taxes
or bracket notation instead of dot
notation so that we can do this so I saw
someone said in there I'd be better to
use John said it'd be better to use
faith and life all together leave out
the hyphens which we could do that it's
true but this is a cool opportunity just
to show a different a different way to
do it
all right let's save that the verify we
don't have errors who we do cannot
Reaper T
okay so we have something that's
undefined here let's see what's going on
this
let's go back to our layout drawer items
this stage riders
all right let's see
this props whoops I messed it up I added
a well yeah I really messed that up all
right
did I get them on I let's change this
alright so I just totally messed up on
spelling so we're in a drawer items and
capitalization lowercase alright let's
see if we get rid of that yay okay we
got rid of that let's verify these still
work great they still work okay so now
that we're passing this down let's go to
our drawer item component and we should
have access to the drawer item property
so it is open so open items let's see if
this works so open items equals this
props is no no we don't want to do it
like that we can can we make this
stainless functionally yeah we're gonna
be able to eventually make this a
stateless functional component so let's
remove this for now and we're gonna
change this in just a minute but for now
we can change this part this collapsed
part it's gonna be this props is open
okay let's save that hopefully we don't
get an error yay everything should be
oops
cannot read open items of null where we
use an open item set
okay have to change it here as well just
make sure it's not being use those fare
drops is open save that alright so we
click it now when I click this nothing
should happen
well actually we get a an error which is
fine that's what should happen because
when we try to run this it's not finding
open items now this is the test that
should tell us whether or not this is
going to be able to work here if we
change let's change about to be true and
save when we go here about should be
open yeah it's open awesome now let's
close it say false and then let's try to
open admissions
yeah missions opens alright great so we
can now control whether or not these are
open and closed by modifying the state
of layout the parent component wonderful
so step two is now finished we can
control the state step three we need to
be able to click it right so we need to
change this we need to use this expand
item modify it a bit to work with our
new system here and then pass it down to
our component instead of having it right
here okay so let's do that now so we
need to make this our expand item we can
keep the name that's great and we need
to make this be open items or a drawer
item so this is going to be drawer item
but what we're gonna do is get the
previous States
let's be open we want it to be true or
false
try times
oops sorry drawer items and what we want
to do
this would be tough so you're gonna send
we're gonna send up that function we're
gonna send in the name the ID and then
all right I think I think we got it I
think I have it let's find let's do this
it's been a little while since I've used
this
it's
this will need to be item ID ID
there are less Asians
whose ID should we do like this this
alright I'm probably messing this up a
lot but here's what I'm trying to do I
think I'm just getting syntax wrong
basically what I'm trying to do is
whatever the state of draw items is I
want to keep it the same and only change
the item that's just happened for the
click so you know if some of them are
already open I want to keep it like that
so let me look up
I object that's this is it the spread
spread syntax
yeah all right so I'm gonna check India
mdn for that objects on objects
I know we'd be done this before
can you say Gerardo's your updated key
okay so rooks I just saw Leonardo says
Jessie you too man thank you I
appreciate that
all right so Rex sites and some stuff
inform pre-staged or items your updated
key value okay that's what I was I was
missing
don't need that no I gave too many
parentheses no now that was the right
amount
I'm obviously
I mean I'll go to these so no messing
something up here
all right consistent spacing is that
what I'm messing up
Oh sir works
alright works and remove that and then
never gonna do
it's gonna be here we go
all right harsh it has some stuff here
[Music]
all right let's see let me copy and
paste
what harsh it has all right so that's I
it's it's cool or [ __ ] let's see okay
drawer items
[Music]
all right so previous state for item
item ID previous age vitamin great okay
cool
thank you hard [ __ ] this was what I was
attempting to do you can see I was kind
of stumbling through it
so let me see I have something wrong
here what is wrong do I need all of
these I think
maybe I don't need that one
oops spelling yet Thank You Brooke items
and what am I doing here unexpected
token alright so let me go through these
so I need this one to close that one and
one to good this is closed here and then
this one is closed here all right great
it should be fine
what is wrong
all right I can't see where this is
going wrong I'm missing
oh thanks oh [ __ ] I'm missing a
parenthesis there oh did I get it wrong
cries a space before what the heck
cause this what they want alright
alright so now previous state is not
defined Oh priest eight that's what a
priest a there we go all right so at
this point
hey Cyril thanks for watching and thanks
for all the help I really appreciate it
okay so we're close now so next step is
pass this function down through props
all the way down to our drawer item so
we got to pass it to drawer and then
from drawer to drawer item and then call
it this function on click
so let's find drawer and what are we
gonna do this let's call it expand item
a and item equals this the expand item
right
Harshit says you definitely need format
on save I know I thought I sent it to
format on save but I guess I didn't
often go back and shut and I can check
my settings again
alright so now we're passing this down
to drawer let's do the same here and now
I'm really wishing I didn't just copy
and paste all these four items but let's
do expand item equals this props span
item and now I'll just do this here
actually let me do it like this little
messy but we're gonna change all this
anyway so now we're passing it from
drawer down to drawer item it should be
available for dried up we can get rid of
this and since we've already called it
expand item that'll be one less thing we
have to worry about so any place where
we have this don't expand item which
should be once good just once we can do
this docprops/core.xml
[Music]
so what do we call that primary text oh
we did we not give it an ID yet all
right we need to give it an ID so I'm
gonna call this item ID that's yeah item
ID and I'm actually gonna take away this
props because we're gonna
we're going to D structure it
so let's do is open and what did we call
this expand item and then now this would
work and then anyway we're doing this
props is open we can change it to just
is open wonderful all right so we're
going to do this and we're going to pass
it item ID so let's add item ID in here
and then let's pass an ID in here so
we'll go with
oh yeah
all right we're gonna say item ID equals
we're just gonna give the idea of first
about to have about and academics
admissions and life wonderful alright so
now we're passing down the proper ID
which will be used to send up on a click
great save that and save that and let's
see what happens a no airs always a good
sign
yay looking at it works it works so when
we do this what's really happening is
the click is calling this expand item
function that's been passed down from
layouts to drawer to draw item so now
it's the click and the data from the
click which is our ID is being passed up
through drawer into layout once it gets
to layout the expand item takes that
item ID and it uses it to change the
state and set whatever that idea is to
the opposite of what it previously was
so either true or false once the state
changes then that triggers re-render and
then that's why we see the change here
so that that's how react we face that's
cool this was really a cool exercise
about state so here's the thing my timer
went off but the last step is now gonna
be pretty easy because all we'll have to
do is in this app bar menu I
is we're gonna pass down that same
expand item function we'll pass it all
the way down to here and then we'll have
an on click our on click that's toggle
drawer let's see so we need we need more
to talk we need songul drawer already
passing in link ID so maybe we don't
need that let's go up to drawer let's
see if this works
where's our toggle drawer it's in layout
isn't it
all right this is probably not the best
way to do it but it's the fastest way to
get it working before I end let's see
her should said he would have stuck for
a half hour if I'd not written that
snippet I don't know about a half hour I
gave it five to ten minutes because I
already had like half of it typed out
let's see we have our toggle drawer
we're gonna pass an item ID this stage
how wonderful and then what we also want
to do is ID and we want to do
all right so here's what I'm doing
Harshit says that's hyperbole well it's
not it's it's close enough to being
accurate that I don't know that it's
really hyper because I mean I'm we we've
all seen me take a really long time to
do something all right let's see okay so
here's what I'm trying to do
so when Thabo drawer is clicked or if
there's an item ID it's gonna expand
that item but if not it's not gonna
expand it right so but it's still gonna
toggle the drawer no matter what we got
to do it like this because sometimes
we're gonna toggle the drawer with the
the button for toggle and we're not
gonna want something to expand
automatically so let's see if it works
the reason I said I don't want to do it
like this because it just seems like my
components from way too intertwined in
different ways right now and it would be
a pain to split them apart and reuse
them that's why I keep saying something
like Redux comes in handy because it
would let us keep our components way
cleaner and more like contained and
reusable this solution works and it
might even work forever for this site
but it's it's definitely not ideal it's
not the best way but this should work so
let's first try this great so we're not
getting an error saying like hey you
didn't pass an item ID wonderful now
let's click about yay and now we've
clicked about and it's expanded great
academics expanded probably what we want
to do though we wouldn't want to keep
everything expanded we would want to
close everything else so the only thing
I would add to this is maybe something
that would if there is an item ID it
would close everything so set everything
to false
and then run this dysfunction so that's
the only difference other than that this
works yay so we can open we can close we
open it's the right one
wonderful let's open it again oh here's
a bug right if we open it and then close
and then try to open again hey it's it's
done so what we want to do then is I
suppose mmm we don't want that to be a
toggle so that's another thing we'll
have to work on we want it yeah we want
to change how that behaves so my time is
up so I'm not gonna work on that now
because basically it works there's just
one little bug that we've encountered
but Wow okay so we got the functionality
that we wanted let me go back up in the
live chat to where we left off and I'm
gonna answer everything in the lab chat
and then we'll wrap things up let's see
what time did I stop
also if you need me to go over anything
that I just did please let me know in
the live chat I'd be happy to go back
over it's possible that I skipped
through something really fast
that wasn't straightforward sometimes I
tend to do that if I start to get into
it that was actually pretty good I
didn't say I won't say I was in like
flow state cuz it's hard to do when I'm
doing a stream but it's pretty close I
haven't gotten into that flow state and
so long I need do a good accent need to
get some work done
alright Evos says quick question what
are your opinions on server-side react
like next you asked for example what
could be better and what are strong
sides I really like server-side reacts
the server-side rendering is nice
I think it's strong the strong side
point is you can your content is
available to search engines which is
awesome you can do caching of the markup
on the server-side which lets you serve
it up really quickly so I think that's
cool I like that as far as what could be
better I really like the way next does
it it makes it easy I suppose it does
require you to use node on on your
server which otherwise you don't
necessarily need to use node with react
not a really problem for me I like using
node but not everybody you know might be
able to use it the other downside I
don't know I don't know that's kind of
it for me I'm sure there are other
things I just can't think of any right
now vivax says what is react is react
like NetBeans or something Andrew says
reacts a JavaScript library for building
user interfaces yeah yeah that's a
really good answer
so yeah check it out if vivek check out
the react documentation it'll explain a
lot more about what react is evo says
it's a library developed by facebook
which allows you to create browser
applications in JavaScript yeah
definitely it can actually do even more
than that but just for like a simple
explanation then keep it like that VFX
says oh like Google developed angularjs
exactly I know they're not exactly in
the same class like angular and react
but for the purposes of this question if
you kind of think of them and being in a
similar category then that's that's
right then that's a good way to think of
it Andrew says I've seen some people
refer to react to the framework but I I
think since it's only a view library
view libraries were accurate I do see
those terms use interchangeably though
Andrew I think you're right on with that
it's really easy to use them
interchangeably I do it sometimes
accidentally but you're right
technically I believe react is a library
and not a framework and for the very
reason that you said it's only the view
so your traditional MVC Model Model View
controller or some people say a MV star
however you want to do it react is
really only the V the view part in that
model whereas something like angular you
could do the entire MVC just with
angular evo says ok in regard to it
being like angular uses it's not really
like anger there are some differences
you should look into them and pick one
you like yeah yeah there are definitely
well probably just explain some of the
differences there its Conda says react
that's crazy start starting learning
this week it's hard hoping to understand
better Big Ups Jesse oh thanks yeah
hopefully that this stream helps a bit
and feel free to ask me any questions
there are some other videos on this
channel that are more like
beginner tutorial on react so check
those out if you get a chance Evo says
Jesse a mechanical keyboard is godlike I
have a cherry MX blue and I love to sit
there all day and type random things and
I really think I might have to get a
mechanical keyboard hey maybe if my
crypto investments take off then I'll
get a mechanical keyboard how about that
yeah but Evo you you make it sound so
enticing I want to try one no bill Billa
kaya says thank you for doing this with
two thumbs up you're welcome I really
appreciate it thanks for watching Peter
says I would highly recommend the Magic
Trackpad - it charges with a lightning
cable and has force touch functionality
and it looks slick AF if you know what
AF means then you know otherwise I'm not
gonna explain it
um alright cool I'm gonna have to look
into that I I maybe I could probably get
my work to pay for that I haven't had
any work-related expenses for a while so
I think it would be it'd be okay I
wonder if I can't pay for mechanical
keyboard I bet I could well let's see
Jacob was saying I need to wrap the list
item with parens in the arrow function I
believe that was for the map but I guess
you don't need the parens yeah let's
check that out for a second our item for
a map with an arrow function did we wrap
it in France I guess we ended up doing
it in parens then we you know what I
think it Otto formatted to do it in
parens but technically you don't need
friends so yeah I think you don't need
parens what is it if it's all one one
can be on one line I forget exactly
which situation you need it in which you
don't but I don't think it's required
although based on ours our rules for our
JavaScript style it we do automatically
put those in I usually don't do it what
I'm actually typing it out but I don't
mind if they get added in it can make
things a bit more readable actually that
I should definitely commit this kids
status double check or get commits see
new feature expand
getting up has a or you know I think
it's Udacity has a guide for the way
they do commits and this is one of the
ways they do it I'm not 100% sure I want
to enforce a guide for commit messages
just yet but it does come in handy your
to categorize things so that's one of
the things I'm considering if you all
know of another guide for commit
messages that you like I'm happy to
check it out it would be probably a good
idea at some point to enforce some type
of formatting of commit messages and do
get pushed origin who now everything be
done is is now available on our repo so
you can check that out and you know
clone it play with it and improve it if
you'd like in submit a pull request
okay so look at something from the react
Docs we were talking about what's he
uses the key earlier when we were
mapping through and it says from react
dogs we don't recommend using indexes
for keys if the order of items may
change this can negatively impact
performance and may cause issues with
component State so works but performance
all right cool
so yeah the order doesn't change here so
it's probably okay to use I usually
never use it unless I really can't think
of anything else but so just in general
I I don't but I guess it's acceptable in
circumstances where the order won't
change
Sanjay says how do you handle responsive
design with material UI does it have
grids or do you write custom flex box it
comes with its own grid components and
that handles a lot of that so a lot of
its kind of built-in if you use their
components properly
let's see random random says what is the
theme variable in the Styles method and
how do components get access to it
alright so to get more info on that
check out the material UI documentation
for the beta version but essentially we
have like this with Styles down here
we're importing it up here as well and
that ties it all together so I don't
really I haven't read the documentation
on that for a while and I think Harshit
might have set it up for this one so I
don't feel comfortable going into it
right now I don't think I could explain
it properly but inside the component
that's how it is if you want to check
out how to set that up in the root then
I would check out the documentation or
check out the repo and see you know kind
of
we're doing in the root component
and see
brooke says capitalization spelling is
the main cause of errors for me glad to
see I'm not alone yeah for sure that's
always the cause of errors brooke says
things like that changing the false to
true makes me really happy for some
reason and seeing it work afterwards of
course yeah it is satisfying
all right hard should I see what you're
saying to change the prettiest Lane
integration to true and editor format on
safe to true I will do that not right
now but I would do that Stephen says hey
Jesse when I hadn't applied a couple
ui/ux
entry web development jobs applied -
sorry mr. - - a couple of ui/ux entry
web development jobs to see what happens
I live in Austin Texas which currently
currently has a ton of openings thanks
for the support
oh yeah no problem and congratulations
on applying I hope you get some
interviews and get a job
so yeah that's awesome and you know
applying to as many places as you can
definitely help your odds of getting a
job so I would say even apply to places
that maybe you think you're a little bit
not you know under qualified for you
never know you know you might you might
get a job so you never know what
candidates they're gonna get but please
let me know how it goes let me know if
you get an interview and sub and you
know good job
get some flying
I should sing change the previous to
true and it will fix the bug at the last
line what here's the thing the I I don't
think it will it'll fix the bug when
it'll cause another one right because
we're using this same thing for our
clicks for this so then what would
happen is every time we clicked it would
just keep saying true so we could open
but we wouldn't be able to close so we
need to do something I need to do
something about that so like I said that
solution will fix one thing and then
cause another bug unless I'm
misunderstanding this solution
Bruce says hey Jesse mind if I ask you a
question about a project I'm doing yeah
no problem
ask away Harshit said without node there
is no server-side rendered react yeah as
far as I know that is definitely the
case Evo says the mechanical keyboard is
really cool you have four different main
types brown black red and blue and you
need to research the differences class a
classmate of mine invest in crypto
it crashed last week and it was so sad
to see also by the way with cherry MX
blue I was referring to the switch style
usually color-coded the brand itself is
a ducky one good keyboard key caps could
be better all right so yeah I'll
definitely I'll do my research on the
key keyboards when I'm ready to purchase
one
yeah the crypto thing is I'm no expert
in crypto but I'll just say it's it's
funny to me sing the headlines because
like I get the headlines you know on my
phone about things going on in crypto
and they're always so behind so like the
headlines will say like oh the crypto
market crashed but then if you look at
the actual prices they already recovered
it moves so fast it's hard for the news
to keep up
that's just it's kind of funny to me the
markets crazy like if you invest
anything in cryptocurrency right now it
better be money that you can afford to
just lose because do I think it's gonna
crash to nothing no but there's really
no guarantee it's just really wild right
now so it's kind of fun I think I don't
think it's a gamble I think it's a
little bit better odds than a gamble if
you if you do it right but it's not a
safe investment at all so I don't want
anybody like taking saying that I'm
endorsing it or thinking you should put
all your money in it right now if you
have a little bit of extra money that
you wouldn't mind losing then I think
crypto is a cool place to put it you
might get lucky on that okay Stephen
says how do you how do teams accept you
when you are under qualified positions I
don't want to go to a job to fail kind
of worries me are most most team
supportive of teaching I don't really
know it would just it would depend on
the team to be honest with you I've
heard people talk about going into teams
and feeling like they don't know what
they're doing and they're not being
supported sometimes they work through
that it's okay sometimes they don't it
really just depends on the team to be
honest with you so you hopefully in your
interview process you'd be able to get
some sort of feel for that but you know
some places just kind of expect you to
learn on your own some places do a
really good job of mentoring it's just
hard to know if if you can talk to
people that already work in a place
that's probably your best way of finding
out
[Music]
Deba prio says hey Jessie when I click
on about and open academics then the
About section remains open can you make
the About section to not remain open
similarly for the other yeah for sure
yeah I definitely want that to be the
case so that's another thing so when
when any one of these are clicked we
want to automatically shut everything
else and only open this oh wait a second
that'll fix our bug that'll fix it hold
on
yeah okay so this this will fix our bug
if the first thing that happens is
everything gets turned to false and then
the one you click on gets open that'll
fix the bug because it'll automatically
be false and then it'll get open every
time you click the only thing that'll
happen is if you try to open it again
this will be open but I think that's
fine I think that's actually a good
behavior so they they Beaupre oh okay so
it's pronounced de beaupré oh they they
Beaupre yo they will pre oh all right
I'm gonna try my best to remember that
thank you for for let me know how to
pronounce that
alright cool you know what let me let's
see
okay wait a second is this not gonna
work
expected average pace all right cool I'm
put that comment in there and that way
I'll remember to write this basically
we'll just have to do something like
this but make set everything to false
yeah that'll work
cool
ego says I have a rather personal
question how did you end up with your
current job and how was your first day I
ended up in my current job so I was
freelancing but it was a little bit
stressful especially for my wife because
we didn't know how much money we make
every month I had some clients so that I
had steady income from but then I had
other times we were just be you know
some months I'd have a lot of work some
ones I wouldn't so that was really
stressful for her not knowing you know
what we have money for this or that you
know not being able to plan and budget
so I decided to start applying for jobs
and I'm gonna be completely honest with
you freelancing I was not making as much
money as I wanted to be making our
family was growing and the I was trying
to get into some other markets cuz my my
local market is economically depressed
right now and it has been for four years
so there just wasn't a lot there was a
lot of high paying jobs it was all
really small jobs and it just it wasn't
worth all the work so I had kind of
broken into the market around New York
City and I started to get clients and
referrals there so things were picking
up but I still thought you know it's
gonna be it'll be a good idea if I to
supply some other places it would
definitely make my white hat wife happy
and we would you know basically have
some more security and stability which
is definitely a good thing when you have
kids at the time I had four know I had
three kids at the time so
I start applying for jobs I actually
took a job and it was a work from home
job and I was in like kind of a trial
period to see whether or not I liked the
job or whether or not they wanted to
keep me but the end of that period I was
gonna get hired full-time so I had
started doing that and I was doing that
for a while and then I heard back about
this job which I had applied two months
before it took a really long time and so
it was kind of a funny thing I applied
for a job called academic web
coordinator obviously I'm not the
academic web coordinator so I didn't get
the job it came down between me and one
other person who happens to be the guy
that works in the office right next to
me there's a really nice guy but I went
through all the interview process they
kept calling me back for more interviews
in person and on the phone and I'm like
why do they keep asking more questions
and finally they called me to come back
in in person again and at that point
them I'm thinking what like what could
they possibly ask me I come in there and
they hand me a job description and it's
for a totally different job and they
asked me what I thought about it and I
said I read over it and I said this I
mean it looks good looks how you did job
and they said good that's what we wanted
to hear would you rather do this job or
the other job you originally applied for
and I said well honestly I'd rather do
this job because it seems like it has a
much broader scope I get to do more
stuff with with the web you know web
development and so they said great we're
gonna offer you this job and we already
offered the original job to the other
guy and so that's that's how it worked
out so I got hired I started a few weeks
later and my first day was just me like
meeting everybody and figuring out where
things were I didn't have a computer for
the first few days because the computer
they had ordered me like just took
forever to come in and eventually I had
there they were another employee had
switched apartments and they hadn't
hired her replacement yet so I took that
computer and put it in my office and had
something to work with for a while
before my actual computer came in so I
don't really remember that much for my
first day other than I didn't have a
computer and an employee Sharon Ann who
I love Sharon and she was like the
office mom and she was so sweet she made
signs for me so there was a signs at the
door little signs on the floor leading
up to the office and just really
welcoming so that was that was awesome
it was a really cool first day everybody
was super nice it was way different than
it is now they totally redid the
building remodeled everything so I
didn't have an office before I had like
a cubicle it was it was weird it was
really wild the building was so
different but that was kind of my first
day so sorry that was a long story but I
guess it answers your question I suppose
so that's how I got here
it's nice they have good health
insurance benefits it's great for the
kids and you know steady income Sal its
salary work retirement plan and my wife
and I and my kids can take classes here
for free it's gonna be a long time
before my kids are old enough to come
here who knows if I'll be working here
by then but if it does happen it will
end up being worth a lot so anyway
that's how I ended up here my original
title was integrated marketing
communications coordinator after year it
switched a front-end developer which is
way more appropriate for what I actually
do but that's that's the story
all right
Oh Harshit says that is exactly for my
name but you don't pronounce it terribly
so I don't pronounce it 100% correctly I
really want to let me know how I was
supposed to pronounce it Bruce say Jesse
sorry what I wanted to ask you earlier
was would you recommend doing the
WordPress theme from scratch or
redesigning an existing theme it depends
on how comfortable you are with the
whole process if this would be your
first time doing it then maybe it'll be
easier to just take an existing theme
and redesigning it I find that to be a
lot easier most of the time and faster
you end up with a lot of stuff usually
that you don't need but it's quick if
you were to start from scratch and
redesign a theme my advice would be
start from scratch and make a basic
theme that you can then copy and reuse
later on so you don't want to be
starting completely from scratch every
single time I think that's a waste of
time but build if you want to build your
own base theme and then just make child
themes off of that I think that's the
way to go because there's a lot of
things that will probably stay the same
from no matter what you want to do so
make that first and then go off it but
as I said it kind of really depends on
what you're most comfortable with
Stephen says the starting pay for almost
all positions here in Austin is nuts I
just need to get my foot in the door
that's cool yeah honestly I when I see
the pay for developers sometimes I get
bigger companies and things I think wow
that would be really nice
it's definitely tempting for me James
says what are some good ways to get
freelance work for beginners if you want
to try to go on the freelance site
sometimes that works I I didn't have
much luck with freelance websites but
some of them you can go to like like top
Tao makes you take a test first and
they're kind of like the middleman
between you and good companies so I I
would be more inclined to do
something like that as opposed to
something like freelancer where it's
basically just a bidding war and who
could be the lowest if you want to go
local I would say just start asking
people and find local businesses that
maybe you can improve their website or
they don't have a website if you really
have time you really need work then just
make a basic website for a company and
then show it to them and say hey usually
I've done for your website you know even
if there's just a mock-up or like a
redesign of maybe just the homepage and
say are you interested in my services I
could build you out a whole website or I
could sell you what I've done you know
sometimes it's easier to show people the
results to convince them that they
really need it you know maybe they don't
realize how much better their website
could be that takes a lot of work and
it's kind of like you put yourself out
on a limb because you're doing work
without getting paid but what you really
do need to do is build up your portfolio
and get those referrals you know maybe
try to target business people in your
area that you know have a lot of
connections and that's where you want to
get if you can if they're happy with
what you do they're way more likely to
tell other people so a lot of local
networking might be your thing if you
want to try to branch out to another
area like me my economic area it's not
great for that then you might want to
try to really target ads or different
SEO at another area a bigger city maybe
it's going to be tough well once you get
your foot in the door and you do a good
job for one company it becomes a lot
easier to do things for other companies
especially if you get referrals you can
try to have referral deals like tell
your existing clients you know if you
refer me you'll get a gift card or I'll
do so much work for free for you that
helps I've done that before all right
okay so harsh it has pasted his name in
Hindi so I can check out google
translate
oh cool our shits name means joyful
excellent that's an awesome name and let
me listen to this
yes she she she
all right I'm gonna work on that that
it's so subtle like I can tell I'm not
saying it exactly right but the
difference is so subtle I'm having a
hard time like grasping it I need to use
I don't I used to take like acting
classes and stuff when I was a teenager
and we would over accents before and one
of the key things to learning another
accent is learning where they position
their tongue in their mouth when they're
talking so maybe I'll have to check out
you know that part of the world with
what's the correct way to place your
tongue and if you can figure that out it
makes it so much easier to to say words
in that language and make it sound
correct so maybe maybe I'm missing
something like that Bruce's thanks I'm
new to developing WordPress themes so
it's a new field for me and that's
really good advice to make your own
basic theme and work from that oh yeah
and there are some bare-bones themes out
there that you could take and work from
so man I can't it's been so long since
I've done WordPress themes I can't
remember what like the the basic themes
are so really sorry about that I used to
know I mean this is like maybe four
years ago I used to know a lot about
WordPress but I've been I've been out of
it for so long I don't even know if the
stuff I used to use is even you know
still in use Ola sauce is how important
to know algorithm and data structures in
front-end web development on a scale of
10 how close a and the yes algorithms
data structures is related to front end
personally in my day-to-day work is run
on developer I don't deal with it that
much but it may come up in an interview
some companies really like to test you
on lots of different things so if you're
if you want to interview try to do your
research and figure out what companies
use the kind of questions they use and
you know you may
want to learn more about that but
personally I've done very little with
that but I don't know I might not be a
good example for the average developer
I'm not really sure
let's see Stephen says the problem that
I have is I'm moving from education 10
years as a teacher I learned HTML CSS
jQuery gets asked bootstrap on the side
for the fun trying to make a move has
been the hardest oh cool I used to be a
teacher as well I taught for almost four
years
and then I moved into freelance web
development so I understand it's tough
to make the move Stephen says just hard
finding a front-end dev job that doesn't
require react angular etc yeah well I
mean try to brush up on your react
skills there are definitely still a lot
of places out there that have jQuery B
based websites so there's definitely a
demand for that it may not be one of the
higher paying jobs right now but if
you'd like to get a job and you don't
quite know enough react yet that might
be a better way to go or even
freelancing there's probably a lot of
freelance work you can pick up that's
jQuery based
DJ says can we use bootstrap and react
you can use bootstrap and react I would
recommend using a react brute strap
library instead of trying to use like
the normal bootstrap I think it'll be a
lot easier for you you'll run into less
problems like that
[Music]
how cool her should put my name into
Hindi and put it in the live chat that's
awesome let's see harsh it says what did
you teach as a teacher I taught Latin
and religion or like theology so I
taught at a Catholic High School so we
have theology classes there which is not
really normal at least in the United
States most high schools don't teach
theology but we did and so I thought I
taught sophomores juniors and seniors in
high school and yeah so it was well I
had a good time teaching I hated the
meetings and I hated all the paperwork
and handling discipline issues I love
being able to help out the students
being able to just like talk to them
about subjects especially I did a course
on like like theology like history like
church history and things it was really
cool to just kind of like tell him
stories of things that happened in
history and that was just fun it was fun
and I I got to you know help out
students get through a lot of tough
things happening in their lives so I
think I really had an impact especially
on you know there's a few students
something I really had a big impact on
and so it was worth all the stuff that I
didn't like just for that but it didn't
pay very much at all it would have been
impossible for me to support my family
on what I was making so and it was tough
I taught 150 students everyday by the
end of the day I had headaches every
single day so there were death there
were things that I did not like about it
but I love my students and I still
talked to some of them and then hear
from and so anyway teaching is cool
teaching is a very very tough job I I
did not think I'd want to go back to
teaching high school
Stephen says I do have nine
presentations at T CEA next month three
at South by Southwest edu and one at
South by Southwest Interactive so I have
that going for me wow that's awesome
you had a lot of stuff going on Stephen
if any of those presentations are
available online I'd love to check them
out so please let me know send me some
links if you're on Twitter you can just
DM me on Twitter if you don't want to
make them like public
they-they-they Beaupre yo they Beaupre
oh all right is trying to pronounce it
right but anyway it says I'm in my third
year my CS degree computer science
degree I want to participate in google
Summer of Code this year what should I
start doing now so the process gets
easier I'm not that familiar with google
Summer of Code so I don't know how much
I can help you in general I would just
say like keep at it like whatever types
of languages or projects that they work
on I would start working on stuff like
that now so you're like in practice for
that just a little bit every day or
every other day will probably help you
let's see
let's see DJ says learning Photoshop
will add any value to web design
yeah Photoshop can for sure there are
some other programs like Photoshop
sketch Adobe XD I think they call it
those ones are all used I think if you
just know one of them you should be fine
but for web design you know a lot of the
Adobe products are usually what people
use hard hard [ __ ] says I'm also
planning to participate in google Summer
of Code this year I've gained quite a
lot of confidence and my skills last
year says that is not the same here man
it is regional let's see
that's cool I'm gonna have to look up
this google Summer of Code stuff I want
to know what it's all about Vince says
in regard to using react the bootstrap
says there is a specific version of
bootstrap that's built specifically for
use with react so if you google react
bootstrap that'll be there so thanks
Vince that's that's definitely helpful
Harshit says but that's ridiculous I
don't know what was ridiculous I don't
remember what I was talking about there
Stephen says if you go to my Twitter
handle I have my education website
listed ok cool
oh uh let me copy and paste your Twitter
I don't know so I don't forget
all right cool I just followed you
it says it's the hyperlink with Stephen
cool I'm on the site right now I'll
check that out thanks for sharing that
okay I'm really exhausted now I need I
need a little break I need some food in
me so thank you all so much I had a
great time well mainly because number
one everything work number two you are
awesome and really helpful and
supportive and positive so I'll be back
tomorrow I'm looking forward to it and
until then have a great day